The joe rogan experience.
I was just on the phone with Alex Van Halen and talking to him about we're going
to be playing at the Tokyo Dome work playing at the big arenas.
They're in Japan.
Yeah.
And I wanted to remind him of exactly what you just described that in the United
States and in Europe you have was like an idling cheer.
A screen that's Ms. Lynch.
It's constant like a car idling.
Yeah.
Idols.
Like a drag racer.
Pluto to be bad,
like you depend on it the way you do your Shpiel,
your talk,
your punctuation,
you know these delays be eating pudding.
You let them go.
Do you stand now?
Say the next thing that you're going to say.
You know,
um,
so you're listening with that and uh,
when American just cheer there's,
it's like a car like,
well I think it's called blower wine.
Right.
And it goes for a long time and if you're waiting like to say something next or
whatever,
you're listening for that and you're listening for it to hit a certain point.
Volume wise.
Your duration wise that you interrupt.
No,
it's a little bit like a dance you follow up.
Otherwise,
if people are making the long noise,
they enjoy them shops,
great.
Let them enjoy themselves.
They love hearing their own power.
Yes,
we are strong or wonderful.
We're young and skinny
is that night in Japan,
you don't get that correct.
You get the Yes,
yes.
Like it's,
it's sort of like a cheering for the ball,
getting spiked in a volleyball tournament and it's quick,
very quick.
And I had said to Al,
you got to remember,
think back how fast the cheer is here that we can't depend on that idling screen
and you know,
and the comedy show and be weird where we get it laughing like,
ah,
I,
you know,
I call it rat pack style,
but it's,
it's just where you've made a connection with the audience,
if pretty much no matter what you say,
as long as it's delivered in the right tone with the right mood is you're a
host,
right.
The worst that I can be on stage is a host.
The best is a really funny house.
Right.
Or are really smart house there.
They'd have fun.
You're there to help them.
Exactly.
So the worst that the least I can do is be a good host.
And that means keep the spirit you have to pay.
No,
especially if something goes wrong.
Oh my God,
the plumbing just exploded,
cried,
then everybody did.
Everybody's instantly,
okay,
great.
It's an adventure,
you know,
as opposed to,
Oh shit,
no,
no.
That's horrible.
Oh my God,
this is,
I want to be here.
This isn't fun.
This is now turning into something other than that's up to the host.
Right.
On a good night.
If you get everybody kind of Holman and bubbling and well fed and watered and
you know,
then,
uh,
pretty much anything you say can be,
yeah,
it's a little bit funny.
Right.
And every now and then I hit a moment.
What?
I'm just Sammy Davis.
Did you ever end up at all when you were done?
Just straight standup?
You ever tried to do that?
Ever have?
Yeah.
I don't think I have the,
I don't have a dining.
I got the cards for it.
It's crazy because you,
you kind of do it a little on stage.
Yes.
It's just a tiny bit enough to sneak up and tap the door and run back.
Yeah.
And then that immediately hit the music.
Boy,
I'm fatigued.
I always have those trapdoors built every like Felix the freaking cat.
I can draw that door anywhere on thin air and go look a song
he had about that fucking brick I just laid out there.
You guys don't have that doors.
So,
but all of my,
uh,
greatest respects to the job you have chosen,
for me,
there's always,
it doesn't even have to wind up funny right from me.
It doesn't even have to wind up clever or anything.
Just shut up Dave B the House.
Okay.
You Ready?
Of course recording.
Oh,
it is already.
What the fuck's on?